well I got interested in in writing
their story when I was researching my
first book impossible subject which is
about the history of illegal immigration
I was in the Labor Department archives
at the National Archives in College Park
and it was one of those things would you
come across a document that you weren't
looking for and this this document was a
report written around 1914 about Chinese
who worked as interpreters for the
Immigration Service and one of the names
just jumped off the page in me was an
interpreter named Frank tape and and I
recognize the name tape now tape is not
a Chinese name so it's very unusual and
we know the name because it was the name
of a civil rights lawsuit in the 1880s
it was a California case called tape fee
Hurley and that was about the exclusion
of Chinese from public schools so I
wondered if this Frank tape was related
to that family so and that was actually
not that hard to establish because you
go back and look at the old census
manuscripts and there he was he was
younger brother of little Mamie tape who
was the girl in the lawsuit here he was
20 some years later as an interpreter
now then I a little a little more
digging turned up the information that
may me grew up and married an
interpreter who also worked is it for
immigration and another sibling Emily
married according to Porter so I thought
well that's really interesting you have
a whole family of interpreters and the
father was he had been an occasional
interpreter but really he made his money
about as an immigrant broker he was he
started with hauling baggage for the
immigrants who arrived at the docks to
Chinatown and that's actually quite
lucrative if you couldn't get them
that's that's usually a monopoly
that's done through the steamship
companies and then he from there he went
into selling bonds to emigrate Chinese
who needed bonds to land and he was also
the passenger agent for the Pacific mail
steamship company and the Southern
Pacific Railroad so that means you got
you know he sold tickets to people and
trying to town and he had a commission
and there who take it so I began to
think of his family as a kind of as
exemplars of a certain class of brokers
in the community who both served the
community but also worked for mainstream
institutions like banks railroad
companies the government the police what
have you and I found them to be utterly
fascinating because first it was one of
the very very few ways you could
actually work outside of the Chinatown
economy or the ethnic economy was one of
the very very few ways you could
actually get a job with an American
institution so it opened a pathway to
kind of social knowledge contacts and
we'll wrap it acculturation process but
it's a very ambivalent position because
you serve two different interests you
know they're kind of marginal you know
to both societies we've got a foot in
each each side needs them but neither
side really trust them so they actually
have a lot of power although they're
very marginal and and I argue that
people like the tapes with really the
first ethnic Chinese Americans they're
really the first generation to be you
know too big have become like like a
hyphenated
identity many people they and many
people like them learned English which
was the critical skill right from
missionary schools either in China or in
the United States and like maybe tape
you know there were the ones who led
some important civil rights battles but
on the other hand they made their
careers through enforcing the exclusion
machine right there their secret to
success was the fact that the masses of
people were well we're extremely
marginally depended on people like them
to get by and Frank himself became
embroiled in some scandals where he was
allegedly where he was actually tried
criminal charges of corruption and
smuggling immigrants so I found this
contrast of you know kind of a civil
rights activity on the one hand and yet
you know arguably criminal and or
corrupt or at least exploitative
activities on the other to be a relief
nating combination and it I think throws
into question what we think of as an
enormity of path of immigrant
incorporation which is that we go from
exclusion to inclusion right we came
here we were oppressed we were
discriminated against we're excluded
then gradually because we worked hard
and we studied hard we became included
right and here you actually see a much
more complicated dynamic where inclusion
and exclusion are intertwined and
constituting each other and and you know
it's kind of a limit case right of what
what's possible what was possible